je suis vraiment très heureuse de la
nouvelle très heureuse de la décision du
gouvernement de reporter nos droits
jusqu en août 2021 parce que nos
artistes nous avons déjà beaucoup de mal
à obtenir notre statut d'intermittent du
spectacle vivant dans un sur un petit
territoire
les écoles nous travaillons avec les
écoles obligé de se diversifier
les écoles ne pourront s'ouvrir que
vraiment réellement en 2021
la saison touristique l'arrivage des
bateaux ne se fera aussi que au moins
dans la perspective de 2021 et par
exemple je travaille en tant qu'ami lieu
à l'atrium
c'est pareil donc je suis très contente
que cela se passe et que les
intermittents du spectacle puisse
peut-être se poser pour faire préparer
les créations à pour l'avenir se donner
du temps
moi personnellement je tâcherai de
travailler sur le projet du musée du
midi daniel patrimoine ok et puis aussi
sous les créations de comptes pour jeune
public et le faire sereinement
voilà en tout cas mes amis artistes
intermittents du spectacle nous avons
une respiration
je vous souhaite beaucoup de courage et
beaucoup de créativité